Hey folks.
Uh,
very good afternoon.
It's great to have you here with ours.
We have sue B and because,
so be as a songwriter who's based in Chicago,
a soupy writes her own songs and sings in both languages,
Hindi and Urdu.
She released her debut Hindi pop jazz album called shatter.
And then last year our album was co presented by the Jazz Institute of Chicago
and she was very recently selected as one of the five artists to be featured on
the Emmy awards winning annual series called Asian influences,
which runs on ABC seven in Chicago.
She has worked with a Yesh Raj fins and the TBF very popular viral fever youtube
series in 2017.
So he was a speaker and performed at a tedx talks and has performed all over the
US.
Some of her notable when news include the SX sw music festival in Austin,
Texas,
the Kennedy Center and uh,
the Millennium Stage in DC and the Rockwood music hall in New York.
Uh,
because the,
Oh,
who's accompanying her is a composer sound designer and on the guitar today,
uh,
and at the way,
and we will have a few minutes for Q and.
A maybe she'll also add in a cover song.
I would really request you folks to silence your phones or any other devices you
have a and we'll have,
so we start from here.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi everyone.
Thanks so much for coming.
Um,
so I'll begin a little bit with my story.
I was 22 years old when I graduated from college.
I was living in New York City and working in Deutsche Bank and I was doing
fairly well for myself,
but I wasn't satisfied.
I couldn't exactly pinpoint what it was,
but I felt like I was missing something.
So everyday during lunch,
in between meetings,
I would go on Wikipedia and I'd start reading about my favorite artist,
who they were,
where did they start,
what were their struggles,
where are they now?
And their stories will always inspire me.
I wanted to do something different,
but I was worried about changing careers.
Is it all right?
Is it too late?
These were the kinds of questions that were occupying my mind and even though I
was part of the corporate world,
I could not stay away from the music and entertainment industry.
So I decided to be a parttime entity and [inaudible] reporter for a couple of
leading for actually one leading South Asian channels in New York.
And my day job would be working on Wall Street and during evenings and weekends
I would cover all kinds of entertainment events in New York,
ranging from movie premiers to concerts to festivals.
I loved into being great artist and I loved learning about their journeys.
So I got a chance to interview some amazing artists like Ara man Suneet each Aha
and recover the Raj,
she [inaudible] Shabana Azmi and three hours of walking at Deutsche Bank I
realized that,
um,
I got this red award red employee award and I figured I'll probably be promoted
soon.
And then guess what I did,
I quit and accomplishment led me to pull back.
Now everyone,
including my family thought it was a ridiculous move because let's think about
it.
I had just quit a golden career on Wall Street to pursue a dream that wasn't
even clear to me and I didn't know what I wanted to do,
but I certainly knew what I did not want.
So I had quit to discover my passion and once I quit I was like this coil
spring.
I wanted to be everywhere and do everything.
So I tried a lot of different things.
By that time I was an entertainment reporter for a couple of South Asian
channels in New York.
I was an audio book narrator.
I started writing and composing for short and independent feature films and I
went to graduate school to study media.
So it was a very exciting and a very chaotic time.
And during this time I was interviewing Mira and I are who I'm sure many of you
know,
she's an Oscar winning film director,
known for movies like namesake,
monsoon,
wedding Salaam Bombay.
And I got a chance to be her music intern.
She was working on monsoon wedding,
the musical,
a Broadway show in New York City.
And when I was working with are,
I realize that passions are supposed to be pursued full time if you're doing it
on the site and it's just a hobby.
I was passionate about,
you know,
music and Bollywood,
but I was running away from it because I thought it was a different world.
It's a distant dream,
but my husband was very supportive and so I packed my bags and I took off to
Mumbai to try my luck in Bollywood.
I had only two friends in Mumbai.
Yeah,
I didn't know anyone in the music industry,
but I was like,
let's see what happens.
So for the next four years,
I did a lot of back and forth between Mumbai in Chicago and it was very
stressful.
I have a shuffling between two continents.
I have to completely different identities,
completely different lives,
completely different group of friends.
And I remember it was a hot summer afternoon and I was riding and Eric shower,
which is a a way good without specify doors or windows.
And I'm coming back after meeting of Bollywood film producer and as usual I'm
stuck in traffic and outside.
I could see these kids playing on the street now,
the games that people playing with the games that I used to play in India when I
was growing up in Delhi,
and it was so nostalgic that I just started singing this melody and the lyrics
just flowed with it.
Yeah.
So I quickly took out my iPhone and in the midst of Mr. Moon [inaudible]
traffic,
I started singing the song as it was being created in my mind.
Okay?
And that's how the song,
but when happened,
the word budge fund means childhood.
Okay?
And this song talks about all the fun games used to place kids in.
However,
Edd was filled with fun and laughter.
Okay,
cool,
buddy.
Daddy.
No,
no,
no.
Did I
just
Duh.
Hey,
what
do you
get?
Both Shim pack
to peak body.
Yay.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Hello.
What do you got?
The conduct Buddha.
Who can look at you,
Gordon?
Not Donkey.
See.
Okay.
Juba goes up.
You Bitch
fucking bitch.
Just about
hey buddy.
Dolphy much fun.
Yeah.
What'd you find [inaudible]
to play?
Oh,
fun to play it.
Love.
Thank you.
So when I was in Mumbai,
I did get some success.
I go to compose for two prestigious digital studios.
Why films?
Which is part of Yerf.
Yeah.
Chage fins and Dvf the viral fever.
Okay.
I also compose for the National Award winning film director,
Nila Ma.
The founder was known for his film I am column.
Okay.
But I was spending more time networking than actually creating music and it
wasn't creatively satisfying.
Okay.
So I decided to move back to Chicago.
Yeah.
And be with my husband.
Yeah,
no.
During these four years between Mumbai in Chicago,
I had created a lot of songs and these songs.
What about my personal life?
About my Jelonese,
my expediencies being in Mumbai,
in staying there,
and these were not really songs that I was pitching to Bollywood and producers.
These were just songs that I created for myself.
I knew that Chicago has a great jazz scene and these songs,
I had created a nice swing to them,
so I forgot maybe they could work well with jazz.
So I posted on Facebook that I'm looking for jazz musicians in Chicago,
and a bunch of people replied.
And through them I got connected to folks in the jazz community.
Initially the idea was just to take two songs,
put them out there and see what happens.
Still,
I figured out what I want to do next.
So the first song that I'd created was much fun,
which you just heard.
And the second song was lovely.
I had created lovely for my love for Chai in TNT,
unless you would shy lover.
And I think it's something that makes me really happy and I feel if I get my
morning cup of Chai,
today's going to be a good deal.
So,
uh,
so I had created the song,
which talks about cherishing this little moments in life and seeking happiness
in them.
And that's what lovelies about
Chell cable,
if you love me.
Hedgie lovely.
Oh
yeah.
Lovely,
lovely
Chai tea.
See Sexism,
which go,
I was
Monaco.
Oh,
awesome.
Good
to plan
you.
Lovely,
lovely.
He loved [inaudible].
Ooh,
Ooh Huh.
Husky.
Awesome.
John.
Lovely,
lovely.
Hey Margie.
He loves me.
He loved [inaudible].
Yeah.
Oh,
lovely.
Yeah.
Oh,
lovely.
No.
Yeah.
Hello.
Hi.
You lovely.
Yeah,
no g kidding.
Who's that?
Who's that Giddy?
So once these songs came out,
I got such a good response that I decided to go back to the studio and release
some of the other songs that I'd written.
And one of these other songs that I'd written is called,
Oh gosh,
the word [inaudible] means in Greece.
And this song talks about being at a special moment with your special someone.
When you're with someone who you love,
you just one time to stop.
You don't want to think about chores or responsibilities,
you just want to hold onto them and being there in Greece.
And that's what our go,
she's about
three.
Yeah.
So mean.
Yay.
Yeah.
Oh
yeah.
Yeah.
Lovely.
Oh shit mean loving.
Okay.
Yeah.
Huh?
Got It.
Yeah,
mom.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Huh.
Hmm
hmm.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Oh
yeah.
Okay.
Josh Eagle.
Mine.
Good.
Oh Shit.
K.
Oh,
she became,
thank you.
So once these few songs released,
I'd only a few songs out.
And before I knew it,
I got my first gig.
I own Indian Organization in Chicago wanted me to perform at their annual
festival.
And this was the first time that I performed publicly with my band in September,
2016 and the performance was well received.
And after that I started getting more gigs and someone asks me,
you such good songs,
why don't you create an album?
And I thought,
yeah,
why not?
So just last year I released my debut album Tan and my album release show was
hosted at the old town school of folk music and it was cosponsored by the Co
presented the Jazz Institute of Chicago.
The show was both a part of the popular world music,
Wayne's d CDs and the official jazz two 2017
and since then I performed at a lot of venues all over the u s including New
York,
San Francisco,
Indiana,
Texas,
Minnesota,
Baltimore,
DC.
And of course Chicago.
In May of this year,
I was selected as one of the five artists to be featured on the Emmy Award
winning annual series Asian influences.
And I was the only artist who was invited to perform at the ABC seven studio
Chicago.
And the best thing is that they found me and reached out to me.
And just last month I performed at the prestigious Kennedy Center and it was
nothing short of a dream come true because if two years ago someone would have
told me that my debut album would be COPD presented by the Jazz Institute of
Chicago,
I would perform at the Kennedy Center at the South by southwest music festival,
give a Ted talk and speak and perform here at Google headquarters.
Today.
I would have laughed at them because I,
I never considered being a singer songwriter as a viable career option.
But it all happened so organically and so fast is none of it was planned.
There was of course a lot of hard work into play,
but most importantly it was all heart and it was all about and believing in
yourself and what you stand for.
And I have a lot of belief in my songs because I,
I genuinely write about what I feel and I try to be as vulnerable and as
transparent about my feelings as I can.
And,
uh,
I really feel that I'm a,
I'm a good songwriter because I,
I genuinely and passionately believe in it and I think that's what it's about
in,
in believing in what you do and in feeling that passion.
This was December,
2016 and I was in India,
in Delhi.
And as some of you might know,
the Indian government had announced the demonetization of the Indian currency
note.
And what that meant was that certain Indian currency notes were banned from the
economy and the Indian government had done this pretty much overnight.
The idea was to eradicate black money and corruption.
But what ended up happening was that there was an acute shortage of cash.
There will be these long lines going to the ATM machine and it would start at
7:00 AM in the morning,
go on until 2:00 AM the next morning and then start again in a few hours.
And I was in India during that time and as a songwriter,
I wrote a song about it.
And so this next song is called Mallarme.
The word [inaudible] means cured.
And the song talks about finding a cure to heal society.
Okay,
come on.
Huh?
Mommy?
Did they
talk?
Nope.
Good enough.
Just say
just
pardon?
Just say
her dad.
Oh Gee,
awesome.
[inaudible] she showed me
Havas
since Sumi Kaisa Caboral pool party or
just say,
whoa.
Just say,
Oh dad.
Just cell.
Pardon?
[inaudible]
Lisa
got
Kayla.
Yeah.
Hey
Dad.
Just,
just snow garbage.
They just
love it.
Her Dad
Mckee.
Nope.
God.
Just sell.
Gabi.
Just say,
just say,
Oh God.
Hey Dad,
dad,
Dad,
dad.
Dad.
Always get a little lost in the song.
I think there's always a battle between the mind and the heart.
And in my case,
it's like the hard always wins.
It's almost like my heart has a mind of its own,
has its own agenda.
And in the beginning I would try to resist it.
And so it took me three couriers to realize that I wanted to be a singer
songwriter.
But once I realized it,
I just let my heart do its thing and it took me on this amazing rollercoaster
ride.
My musical journey and my debut album have been a very unpredictable experience.
Something which might care free play,
full and naughty hearted planned for me.
And hence the name of my debut album is this carefree,
playful and naughty heart.
All chat on bill.
I want to leave you guys with two thoughts.
Firstly,
I think it is all right not to have a plan.
In fact,
I'd say maybe it's better not to have a plan because then your mind is free and
you get a chance to follow your heart.
And so I can lead is really important to just keep trying.
I heard this beautiful thing that goes like this in [inaudible] he will die.
Just not,
oh sheesh.
Carnevale the van.
So in other words,
if you keep waiting for things to happen,
then you will only get what the hustlers of left behind.
So keep trying new things.
Think outside the box,
follow your heart because unconventional changes the world.
And I'm so thrilled to announce that I'm,
I'll be releasing the first single of my second album.
The single will be out next Friday,
which is September 14 on all digital platforms.
It's called Gloria.
The second album is going to be a very easy listening album,
which is vocals,
guitar and drums.
And the single is called Gloria.
And the word Korea means dog.
And what the song talks about,
it's about a girl who's getting married and she's telling her mom that she's
ready to be a bride and she's ready to take on a new role,
enter a new journey in her life and make new relationships.
And the song also touches upon all the Indian traditions,
which are part of such auspicious occasions.
So we wanted to end on a happy note and here is Korea
such
as
the juggle.
Yay.
Oh boy.
Duty
Shan.
Tell him
put your keys.
No
to barking.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
yes.
Whoa,
Duh.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And uh,
that's it.
Thank you guys for listening.
I would lets me her depo.
So will be,
can you tell us a little bit about your journey and how you got into jazz
specifically and how do you get along with it now?
Yes.
Uh,
you know,
I have ghost.
I of course had heard jazz like when I moved to Chicago and I knew Chicago is so
awesome for Jasmine.
Um,
so I,
you know,
I'd been to the green moves and Andy's jazz showcase,
and I also went to the Monterey jazz festival in New Orleans.
And so clearly I think as an artist,
jazz was there in my subconscious mind somewhere.
But I had,
I'd never imagined to do dive into jazz.
Like that wasn't even a plan.
But after,
uh,
after I moved back from Mumbai,
yeah,
I just knew that Chicago is so good for jazz.
And I think it was just,
I just took a John's like,
I think buch bone and lovely,
and they all had a,
had a very nice swing.
So I was like,
you know,
let's try it.
And initially it was just two songs.
And,
um,
and then I've,
you know,
I,
I enjoyed it and I think it was a very,
uh,
challenging,
it's an AA challenging John Doe in general,
but for me,
because I come from an Indian background,
I'm used to Indian music or Bollywood jazz was they different.
So for me to I to learn about jazz,
I had to learn about improvisation and foam,
which improvisation is very new to me because as pop,
you know,
you don't really improvise.
It's just,
you know,
the intro is,
and you know,
the music interviews and you come in when you have to come in.
So I think all those things where it was,
it was a very fun experience and a,
and so initially it was just two songs.
And then like I said,
I just started getting gigs and I didn't even have enough songs to do the gigs.
And,
and then I,
I started proactively getting involved and,
and with my album being a co Co presented by the Jazz Institute,
that was like,
yes,
you know,
and then I just got more into it and I'm,
I'm still learning jazz.
So let's see,
I have a quite a way to go with it.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Um,
with our last song,
it brought good memories to my own wedding and how emotional it gets with your
family around you.
And honestly,
those were Indian weddings are big,
like the few hundred people and they bring in the emotions with them.
So it was amazing to bring back good memories.
Um,
so I hope you guys enjoyed the show.
It was very beautiful.
It was a great start to my weekend.
It's very unconventional that I go to music gigs like these,
but short inspires me to,
you know,
achieve my own dreams.
I do have some,
I will get there.
And then she has these really unconventional story she brought in,
uh,
all her own wisdom along with her.
So I hope this,
this lines up straight up for some thinking for your weekend as well.
But I line up,
um,
like I was saying,
you can line up for questions over here.
Uh,
but I'll get to my next question.
So what's next for you?
You mentioned that you have a second album.
Can you describe a little more of the team,
uh,
your thoughts along with it?
Sure.
So,
um,
I actually want to explore other genres.
And the first album was pop jazz.
So for the second one it'll be like an acoustic album with vocals and guitar.
I think I'm going to dive more into folk.
Um,
I'm Punjabi.
So I also want to dive into Punjabi music.
And a Hindi is of course,
so it's going to be a folk pop and a very acoustic,
easy listening album with more focused on vocals.
And I'll try to bring in some of my improvisation from jazz,
whatever I'm learning and kind of mix it with folks.
So that's the plan.
Thank you.
So we have a question here.
Thanks.
It's really very impressive.
I mean,
and your voice is fantastic.
Um,
I'm curious,
uh,
it sounds like there's an influence of Brazilian jazz.
Um,
so I wanted to ask if there was anything that kind of drew you toward that,
a category of jazz.
And then secondly,
I was curious to ask,
uh,
have you ever pursued or received a formal training,
um,
voice training,
compensation training?
This is,
it's really,
really good.
Or is it just come?
It just comes.
Uh,
so the first question with resilient jazz,
I would like to give credit to the cards for this one because he's actually,
um,
I was initially doing just jazz with my band,
with my jazz and my band were all jazz musicians in Chicago and that was just,
um,
Chicago jazz fuse with Indian music.
And that sounds very different.
I met because,
because I was introduced to him by t Alexander,
who's a really,
really popular jazz artists in Chicago.
And because his style I think has a lot of Brazilian jazz to eight,
if I'm not wrong.
Yeah.
And,
and so when,
when,
um,
when the idea came to take my songs and we're working as a duo,
I think it really opened my ears to that style of jazz.
And so I think there was a lot of give and take.
Like I,
I learned from the way he was playing on how to phrase my,
my lyrics or how to work around my songs.
And so that influence I would say,
comes a lot from,
from the exposure I've had by working with because,
um,
and for the second question,
which was about formal training.
So,
um,
I grew up in Delhi and I moved to the states when I was 15.
So I received about eight years of Indian classical training in India.
And when I moved to the states,
I didn't have a guru when I couldn't,
I couldn't find anyone.
So I didn't continue that.
And then I,
I had vocal coaches at abroad.
We coach and as an a coach who was working on Broadway.
And so my,
I was part of the choir.
I used to sing Christmas carols at senior citizen centers and Events and
festivals.
So I think my,
um,
my style isn't a Indian classical anymore.
It evolved.
And,
uh,
I'd,
I'd like to say it's kind of like indoor western.
It's a,
it's a kind of like a mix.
Uh,
and that's purely because of geographical reasons because of being in the US.
And,
uh,
and I think I've,
right now my coach is an opera singer,
so I'm also learning techniques that way.
So it's been a blend of a lot of different styles.
Uh,
so that's what it is in writing.
I've been writing ever since I was in school.
So the lyrics and everything are just from what I observe,
I just write it down.
So thank you.
Since you sound awesome.
Like imagine chasing your childhood dreams from writing to singing and now
learning from an opera singer.
She's more inspiring by the minute she talks.
So we have a few minutes.
If there are no questions she can sing a cover for us.
Um,
so we feel comfortable.
We can do one more song.
Shane,
keep the show running if you guys want to hear it.
Sure.
Okay.
Um,
so this,
uh,
discover that we'll do it.
It's called an India Arie and uh,
in India means sleep.
And this is actually a lullaby where this guy is a calling,
sweet,
sweet sleep to come and,
um,
help him fall into these dreams and into his fantasy world.
And um,
this is a coke studio song.
If he's released on Coke Studio,
Pakistan,
the artist who had composed the song,
his name is [inaudible],
she's a Pakistani artist.
And I absolutely love his work.
And,
uh,
so this is our rendition of his song.
Mm.
Yeah.
Ooh,
yeah.
Yay.
No,
Eh,
uno.
Yay
Nia.
Shit.
Oh.
Oh,
you can cheat.
[inaudible]
got it.
Damn
Eh,
buddy.
Hey,
eh.
Thank you.
Bye.